- It has the glossy top
and it's quite like flat
and a good size. (laughs)
- What are you talking about?
(laughter)
- So, we are in Germany.
- In Berlin.
- Yeah, and we are going to
try some McDonalds here and see
how it is different from
the American McDonalds.
- Those other places we don't
really have them that much
compared to America.
McDonalds is the place to
go to for a burger, recently
we got more and more..
- So the burgers aren't
that big in Germany.
- Not really.
We love, sausage and
brats or sausage in brats.
- This is a Signature
Collection Classic Chicken,
this looks like really fancy.
- There's a lot of stuff on there.
Onions, chicken, bacons.
- Cheers.
Oh wow, it's really good.
- The chicken is a good quality.
- There's like mustard on top
and ketchup on the bottom,
so both sauces go really well.
This is like the classic one,
so there's nothing really
more added.
Other than the bacon.
- It's fabulous to me.
It's decent.
- Signature Collection again,
but beef special, which has
bacon and egg, so it's
not classic it's special.
- I'm expecting a lot now though,
- Me to, I know, the chicken was so good.
- It's already falling.
- I'm really interested in the egg.
- I like the taste actually
even more than the chicken.
- You like it more than the chicken.
- I'm more like a beef type anyways.
- You're a beef type.
- Yeah, I'm a beefy.
- You like some beef.
Oh wow that's a huge burger.
That's really big, that's just
like a normal thick burger.
- I see barbeque sauce I see
white stuff, nothing special.
- Nothing German about them.
- No.
- These are happy fries.
- Look a little bit like you.
- Oh, it's very bready, I know
a lot of people like crispy
but I like this.
- They have like actually
different faces and that
makes me happy.
We have a lot of bad
weather here recently.
- Hello, maybe that's why
they have the smiley faces
in the fries.
Chicken Box, chicken nuggets
and some chicken wings.
We're going to eat with
the sweet and sour sauce.
Suess-Sauer?
- Suess-Sauer.
I guess if you're really craving chicken.
- That's good.
- You can go get a chicken box.
- Not bad.
- You know what they
should do, they should do
the chicken box also
with the chicken burger,
so it's like triple chicken.
Okay thanks, thanks for
reacting to it (laughs).
So, we got some McFlurry, I
always get Oreo in America.
We tried to get some different flavors.
Mine is the caramel one.
- Mine is called smarties.
- Smarties, what's that?
- M & M's basically.
I love McFlurry.
- Oh, it's sweet.
Oh yeah, that's like little chocolates.
So what was your favorite?
- I like the chickens ones,
(laughs) the McFlurry.
- I like the Classic Chicken burger.
Signing off from Germany, Danke Schoen.
- Danke Schoen.
- I'm eating all the rest (laughter).
- The leftovers?
- All the leftovers, that's fine.